oh yeah this Monday is Tuesday whatever
day is what every day who cares man you
know I'm saying the Sun is a Sun up or
is it not up
are you alive that's really where that's
really where you got to start in my life
okay then well let's go a little bit of
Stevie starlight
man I'm man
same
to come
why must we wait when we are alive man
this is it you got nine pints of blood
in your body then you you're ready to
rock you're alive you are alive and that
is it nine pints I don't even know what
it is producer premature Nick isn't here
with me today what's going on Theo not
much how much blood is in the body Nick
nine point pint sounds a little light to
me if I'm gonna be completely on really
yeah yeah maybe some well yeah if you
got whittled overdo it if you got 12
pints in your body then I think you're
greedy but I think maybe I guess 10
pints seems like a good amount to have
1.5 gallons so that equals so now you
get him British now you getting British
on me let's see that is you 12 pints
you're very close I was I was wrong
really yeah I thought it was just I
would have said hundreds I don't know oh
no it's not well nine pints hidden that
mean if you only have nine he's licked
up twelve you're gonna have kind of a
squishy handshake I feel like like a
damn uh damn buddy you feel how your
hand feels kind of malleable you know I
think you might be a little light on the
blood you know I notice a lot of people
have different people are getting so
unused to shaking hands anymore that
there's a lot of there's a lot of um
weird you know a lot of unique hand
moisture I'm finding out there because
you know on the road I'll shake a lot of
hands and so you shake a hand man Hannah
sometime like cold so my tongue somebody
have a real cold hand I'm like damn bro
you did man there you might want to see
where you are you living in a coffin cuz
you seem a little you feel a little dead
or you'll have somebody have a real wet
hand there's one guy could I try to
shake his hand I could even get a grip
on her just kept it kept sliding right
out of my hand
and finally I was just like oh let's
just don't be friends bro you got a you
know you got to show up with at least
semi-dry hands I think to a to a
handshake but what the [ __ ] do you want
now thank you guys for being here with
us today I just got back from Dallas and
it was a good time man
I had well well what was your weekend
like net lista it was super-fun
so I've got two older sisters and okay
one of them has visited out here many
times you met her Natalie she's the one
has the colonics business oh yeah and
colonics that's washing up people's butt
mm-hmm Wow well speaking of colonics
dude go on so they were out here very
quickly I would love to get to film you
getting your your you getting a colonic
for my sister I think we could that
would be super fun
dang dude out it's almost seems like
incest I think it was me for sure well
if you're in the room when it happens
during her sister's giving a guy a
colonic then that is that should how was
that not incest I would way rather kiss
my sister then be in the room when she's
washing out the inside of somebody's
butt that's fair that's fair but you
know we're just kind of funny that they
don't make like a butt gargle or
something that we can use as humans
mm-hmm
you would do so much up top on the front
whole we don't do a lot on that back end
that's true but now we got bit elegance
well that is true and we'll Tyrell okay
well it's a poor way to get in one of
our sponsors uh for more small business
we'll get right into it this is a small
business a little accident right there
yeah there's a happy little accident but
delegates now some people were wondering
what what are you talking about and well
I'm going to tell you but delegates is
do you know that European royalty have
long used bidets to cleanse themselves
after using the restroom while the
bourgeois have used dry ineffective
toilet paper and never truly been clean
you're talking about decades and
centuries of just real soiled bottoms
you know dirty bottoms DB's they call
them until now things have changed and
that's bad elegance but elegance is a
natural
cleansing foam that brings you luxury
and elegance of a bidet with the
convenience or conv anyong of toilet
paper you apply but elegance you get a
hit of this ba'd elegance and you apply
that moisturizing cleansing foam to
toilet paper and and it turns that dry
cleaner total paper into that wet clean
and you can get your privates so if you
have private severy buddy has privates
mostly unless you were in the war or
something or unless you know you had a
bad incident with some cult then
everybody has privates and embed elegans
can help it's better than dr toilet
paper it's better than wet wipes it is
more cost effective it's
anti-inflammatory praise god it's
soothing it keeps your hands dry does
not harm sewer systems and it's
eco-friendly right now but elegance is
available on amazon.com with free
shipping that's bi de le gan c e on
amazon.com with free shipping
but elegance get that bottom cleaner
speaking to duty I'll tell you who could
use that is uh I was on the place I'm on
the plane to Dallas and man there is
somebody just just puff and butt out
into the air you know somebody just
doing you know body gas and I don't look
I don't mind smelling one or two you
know I'm human you know I'm hell I'm
even a little curious you know I don't
mind you know being like you know
playing a little game a who done in the
air if somebody's you know tootin you
know doing you know body gasps you know
puffing out there but but this dude
whoever this dude was just kept I mean
this guy was like a damn locomotive I
mean every minute and a half it would
just be just the air would feel sold it
one felt at one point the air felt hot
in the air no like I'm close to this the
deal so I started you know snout and
around and I got that big face piece you
know it's all really I cannot just smell
a [ __ ] dude I can smell somebody you
know I could smell somebody drinking a
sprite
from probably about 60 feet away so
immediately I was like while I smell
around and it's the guy in front of me
and it's just coming off and felt hot up
there by him the air was probably 2
degrees warmer up there by him he's in
the seat in front of me
so finally dude after about the 7th time
I [ __ ] woke him up he was asleep or
pretending to be asleep and just farting
and I was like bro do Dustin you nasty
man is he you nasty you being nasty out
here all these people stuck in hearing
you over here doing that and he looked
at me he was gonna make me say oh that's
not me and I said that's you that's
gross that's gross you're an adult and
bruh he didn't do it anymore and I felt
bad his wife was sitting right there
behind and you could tell he's probably
done in his whole life and his wife duh
you know she at this point tired of she
got tired of speaking up about 13 years
ago and this guy looked like just like a
damn sofa cushion at a frat house I mean
just [ __ ] tattered you know didn't
really care about himself and look I
don't mind you drop a couple in the air
you know I'm not an Air Marshal dude I
don't want somebody throwing around a
little bit of butt Isis but when you hit
hard like that and you're coming in 60
70 times it just made me sad it just I
felt at a certain point like it was
personal mm-hmm that make any sense yeah
totally and you had to play the role
that social assassin you you helped
everybody on the plane oh yeah
I shut him down and I even told the dude
next mess hey bro I'm going in you know
I love it I said if I don't come back
and about you know thirty Seconds even
though we're just sitting next to each
other I didn't move I say you know come
in and get me sometimes you're helping
that guy out for his future he's gonna
be able to make friends better I had to
do that in this building we're in a
couple times
I've I've had to go number two right oil
it and ice it down there and there's
peace flatter'd all on the seat and I
caught one guy he's standing up and
peeing into the toilet with the seat
down he walks away and then I sit in his
urine I was like hey man either use the
urinal or lift the seat and then pee did
you say that I did Wow I've got it I've
done two different people in this
building I've told them to not do that
and these are adult yeah
and also it made me look at myself
because I think I may be spending too
much time in that bathroom yeah but yeah
what are you doing do it in there just
brakes you know man it's something you
might be taking too many breaks bro
there's no windows in here so oh that's
true
there is no windows in here man but uh
so that's it was a bit much that that's
different from when you had your
airplane boner because your airplane
boner that's not bothering the people
around you that you should just be able
to have this guy is ruining the rest of
the plan yeah look if a boner cuz that's
the thing about gas it comes out of you
and then it goes and bothers other
people you know it'll tap you on your
[ __ ] nose shoulders and then it's in
your brain and then you [ __ ] part of
something that was inside of that man is
inside of you now and dude that should
be that should be illegal really because
it should be illegal imagine if I sold
you this I'm gonna take something out of
the inside of my butt and put it in your
nose you'd be like [ __ ] no bro we're not
doing that and that's what that man's
doing but if a boner came off your body
wouldn't hit people in the room then
that would be I think obtrusive you're
intrusive but anyhow but ya got down
there to Dallas and what else happened
down there dude oh they had some psycho
lady trying to come get a cut of that
[ __ ] that babies you know daddy's
body D you know that air boner you know
that [ __ ] frequent flyer man and this
lady was a BSc brother batshit crazy you
know and she started saying that she
thought people were talking to her sub
sub sub consciously through Instagram
videos and I was like this is so bizarre
man so I had to avoid that pitfall and
what else man I don't know what else
have we did she had family in town and
what yes I'm just tired man I am
exhausted literally got in you know left
at 6:00 a.m. from Dallas and landed here
not too bad at like 8:30 and then went
home took a nap for an hour but I
probably got two and a half hours of
sleep last night so which I'm not
complaining is just it's just hectic
mm-hmm you know so what about you man
yes I was saying my my sister Natalie
she's been out here a number of times
the one with the clients business but my
other sister has yet in my four years
she hasn't been out to LA yet so her and
her husband flew out and they're leaving
for a cruise on Monday but we spent some
time on Saturday she's a huge Bravo
television fan oh yeah she loves a
Vanderpump rules so her big thing what
we went to Sur a pump and TomTom which
are all like the same owners of that
show it was all it was all over my head
I'm not familiar with it but she was
very excited she met some Real
Housewives oh really
from which humor which city yeah she
they were Dallas oh and I was in Dallas
oh yeah
small world yeah but and one of them was
Brandi and I thought didn't you date a
housewife Maria but it was a different
angle and Bulls yeah yeah this is she
was of Jerry Glanville's daughter you
know that I did not yeah
oh wow that crazy yeah that's a lot I
told me that uh it sounds right but it
would be actually yeah it could be who
knows who [ __ ] knows dude remember
Jerry Glanville brother I do is the [ __ ]
man with Andre Rossi killed Andre Rison
didn't he didn't somebody kill Andre
Rison uh Lisa left eye Lopes
unbelievable no she burped her in jail
she burned down his house yeah well she
got her karma kinda why she died in a
plane crash well super sad and mean Nick
really bringing this episode to a whole
I'm sorry that's okay
so you guys went to the pump and it was
good what's it like in there like is it
basically a lot of fans at these
restaurants who were trying to see you
know the the people that they liked it I
didn't see it there were a ton of people
getting pictures in front of the sign
okay but they weren't like approaching
the staff at all it's just like it just
seemed like a higher-end West Hollywood
nice restaurant type vibe with to a lot
of music plan okay and the staff is at
the same cuz under the show used to have
the staff I remember when the show first
came out and the show had the staff on
it did the
did they are they there still is at the
same time so yeah she I don't think she
saw any like the the real main
characters but she was definitely
pointing people oh and she's like that's
but that person that's that person she
was so unabashedly excited it was real
he's pretty adorable to be honest and
now does she have a husband or not yeah
yep her husband came out - what's his
name Tony
Oh Tony Wow Tony Kirchner and what does
he like now how was it how was the
husband dealing with this when the wife
is you know you know getting all fired
up he he just thinks she's hilarious
it's definitely not his scene he
definitely doesn't watch those shows but
he's a trooper he was like wherever you
take me I'll sit here and drink and you
can have your fun nice Wow so pump a lot
of chicks in there a lot of dudes in
there what was the vibe in there tons of
which I thought was really interesting
tons of groups of girls out together no
man must be like a pregame type
situation right so I thought I found
that interesting we have to revisit
there you wish you two dressed up more
when you when you got there not yeah I
have one button-up shirt essentially I
wear for any quote unquote nice events
and that's what I rock so I was
comfortable with my choices Wow
the premature Nick making adult choices
out there oh and on Friday I went
bowling at pins this is unrelated uh-huh
and I bowled next to miles teller from
whiplash oh really
yeah he was with a group of people a
drummer yeah yeah wow that's pretty cool
yeah it was super fun and he looked like
he was incognito he had like a hat on
like a mustache he looked like he had a
mustache yeah hit him mustache on him
Rhea want a fake one I didn't get close
enough but it looked pretty authentic
huh what a crate come back in the day
people would wear fake stuff you know if
you didn't want to be recognized people
would you know somebody might wear a
trench coat and tie one of their legs up
under there bottom of the coat you know
him like all that like I was that uh you
know is that Danny DeVito you like oh no
that guy only has one leg you know even
though it is him just balance and well
and hiding from fans you know where
you'd see like um who else dude am I
thinking a problem
a Sigourney Weaver you know and they put
like a uh you know they do like a neck
brace maybe and um those you know blind
glasses now blind people walk around
with their eyes out mm-hmm you know
which is a little I think that kind of
ever since um The Walking Dead people
are kind of doing that more I think it's
a little bit much sometimes but when I
was young bunky about these huge glasses
on so and I don't even know why but
you'd see celebrities would do a lot
more hiding and now it's just more like
you know they're just right there just
bowing right next year pins yeah
Hollywood Wow fake mustache show kind of
a turn back the clock yeah man I'm
trying to think of what else to even
talk about I had we start the pilot this
weekend so some people don't know the we
did a man a show called man up on Comedy
Central we did three episodes that are
digital that are on there and website
and on YouTube and and it was great it
was all based on the podcast about
people that call in and and want to be
involved in a you know just wanting
suggestions it's talking about stuff and
so we we now we're doing it again
so now we're doing one that is an actual
pilot and when things go from being like
a digital series to a pilot basically
there's like a bigger budget so that's
what I'm learning so like they give us a
bigger budget to make the pilot with so
you can have like you know an extra
camera person you can have more sound
you can have more time with an editor
you can go to different locations so
anyway it's gonna be fun then I'm really
really excited Jon Lovitz is gonna be in
I love Jon Lovitz yeah that's a bad
impersonation yeah that's a bad
impersonation of anybody uh okay no [ __ ]
I don't have any I can't wait to be on
man up okay let me see if I can you try
that one that's good
I can't wait to be on man I know you won
this one um here I'll do Morgan Freeman
off against you all right you go first
that wasn't mine of me laughing he
crawled through hundreds of yards of
that's nothing
Wow back is that an average husband if
your sister's colonic company that's
like you were doing here I got one
they said it would take a man six
hundred years to get out of this here
prison but I had to do frame they didn't
let them want him I was good you tied up
tied up tied up on this very sewerage
system episode we're cleaning up the
pipes man we're stayin alive brother I
mean it look bowel movements are one of
the top keys that you're alive like if
you're but when you don't people always
hate bowel movements and I'm like dude
if you don't have bowel movements
you're dead brother not only that you're
gonna fill up with duty so you got to be
really grateful for that you got to be
really really grateful yeah what else
man what else
we had some news stories yeah hit me
with a little bit of those men I'm sorry
I'm so blanked head him in uh ladies and
gentlemen I just have feeling I don't
know I just feel tired you know I just
feel like I just want to just I wish
somebody would just breast feed me some
[ __ ] carrot juice hmm and uh you know
wouldn't it be awesome just a big garden
me [ __ ] just show up and just spray it
in my mouth until I [ __ ] go to sleep
boy
oh god I'd love that then when we were
we were young my mom put a little bit of
syrup in our mouth if we were good you
know mm-hmm pretty cool and it's pretty
cool so what do we got so on Friday we
had our government it was the 35th day
of the government shutdown but we have
now temporarily temporarily resumed
government operations there's a
three-week deal in place where they can
try to negotiate the budget all based
off Trump trying to secure funding for
his campaign promised border wall okay
and but at the moment were the
government's back in business and he has
yet to secure that funding okay so
they're still arguing about that money
huh welcome to the world money in walls
yep
money in walls yeah it's kind of
baffling I think there's been a lot of
like chess play in between these
politicians and I like a lot of it I
mean look I mean I'm not affected by the
government shutdown so you couldn't take
my voice on what that's like you know as
an employee as a worker so I don't
really have an understanding of that I
mean I could speculate but I just think
if you if you spend all you if we spend
all our time if we spend all our time
like thinking about the government you
know saying the government should do
this and we should do this I mean the
truth is like we should do it like if
you want to help people coming across
the border and people who are you know
extra you know leaving fleeing other
countries then take a family into your
home because in the end we are we're
America people always like America
should do this and I and I'm guilty of
it too but we are America it's just the
people like I you know so many rich
people are like this that you think you
help you can actually afford to help you
could afford to adopt one of these
children that's you know over there
you know that's showing up you know with
no family at the bar like because we're
America so instead of pointing a finger
you know
lend a hand it's like it's like because
if we don't do it that it
we're all America is just the people
we're it it's like if we don't do it
there's no we're just yelling at these
you know this shell of like people who
are now just ego maniacs it seems like I
mean politicians have become a lot more
known amongst everyone by their names
now so a lot of ego comes with that it's
a lot more popularity contest I mean you
see them they're just fighting on
Twitter all the time and I'm glad they
fight their pilot they're elected to
figure it out and to argue into when
they're all getting along man that's
when to me I don't try to trust I trust
that even less because this way you get
to hear who's who you get to find out
who's who you get to hear their points
of view and stuff like that but I mean
I'm all for more organized border
security you know I don't think it's
safe to have like I always say it's like
if you don't have proper inventory then
you can't run a business it's much
harder to run a business and I know
people aren't inventory I get it but you
know imagine if in kindergarten they did
roll call and you got 19 people in a
room with note with no names and they
just hiding behind the raincoats and
behind the little sandwich you know
cubby holders the [ __ ] is that so you
just have to find ways to incorporate
everybody get everybody out and little
light where people can live there live a
real life live in existence live a truth
and then also when you get when you know
who's who you know who is a criminal you
know who is a good person and it gives
us a chance if we have an organized
system where people are coming into the
country then it gives you a chance if
you're somebody that can afford to help
out say you got an extra room you got an
extra house you can get in a you know
I'm sure a program would start where you
could find out you could interview
people and have somebody come and stay
with you if you wanted to help them get
indoctrinated into America help them
figure out what it's like
it's [ __ ] scary you got people
running through barbed wire and [ __ ] at
night it's disorganized you got
vigilantes out there throwing grenades
at people you know you got you got
people falling into traps but--
quicksand you got all of this [ __ ] so
but i'm glad to see these politicians
arguing I mean it's just we live in a
wild world where it's like are we really
you are we getting the real information
are the choices we make making even
based on the information based on letici
so then if if you're making a choice is
it even based on real new you know I'm
saying it's very tough to decipher but
one thing that isn't tough to decipher
is if you quit looking out here as to
what's wrong and just worry about
yourself and if you can help one other
person then help him out you know you if
you're so upset about the you know like
that people are coming in and don't have
water go down and give him some [ __ ]
water Duncan Trussell when he was in
here he said a quote that I think about
all the time and he was he was quoting
someone else but he said ten to the
garden you can touch yeah so like you're
saying whatever you have the ability to
affect and help that's what you should
put your time and effort into rather
than worrying about things you can't
control
yeah yeah I like that man tend to the
garden that you can touch yeah cuz it
you know sometimes I notice it's an
escape it's an escape point I don't want
to deal with my own problems I'll start
looking I'll start getting angry about
the other stuff about the bigger picture
stuff that I cannot do anything that I'm
not or that I'm not going to do anything
about you know I noticed when I start
using my voice to get things done
instead of my feet you know that's
usually when I have to think for I got a
might need to think a little bit more
are usually actions with your with your
feet or ones you're probably gonna be
able to actually get done you know but
it's hard but it's interesting you know
it's hard not to fall into the you know
to get caught up in the complacency of
just of just pointing fingers you know
it is hard and it's almost one of the
blessing I mean
it's not I mean it's almost one of the
things that people like to do too
people like to just share their opinions
and you know and give this an that about
the government and it kind of gives if
there wasn't the government that you
don't really have anybody to be pissed
at it's true you'd have to take a look
good long hard look at yourself yeah
like what if the government was just a
big mirror anybody [ __ ] were really the
government and what am i yeah am i it's
wild it's well there's a lot of other
issues I mean America is you know things
used to be built here and made here and
there was a different idea for jobs and
a lot of things got outsourced and
cheaper labor and when America became
more of a place that wasn't it went from
being a like countries went from being
national to being international so you
know everything's gonna change then then
you become like more of a marketplace
and you become more of a of a stop in
the world instead of your own just
yourself and we and it just becomes you
know products become cheaper over here
so suddenly all those jobs go there all
this goes there and the infrastructure
that you know was once more national at
one point isn't now a lot more
international but then that's life it's
like life like some people lived in a
time when they had [ __ ] their whole
life was just looking at some
hieroglyphics or something and guess and
what it was pictionary you know walking
around like in a cave and guessing
pictionary and thinking what people did
what they were trying to tell them
through pictures on it's like
everybody's had you just show up in a
timeline of the universe and here you
are and some people were alive when they
only had [ __ ] cannons which was
awesome can you imagine that you [ __ ]
pissed at the neighbor they think you're
not [ __ ] but two days later dad comes
home with a [ __ ] cannon and points it
at their house now you'll keep your dog
[ __ ] out of my yard different times man
what else we got Nick going on out there
see a 21 year old Louisiana man
mmm-hmm was arrested after a manhunt he
was captured in Virginia and he is
suspected of killing five people
including his parents but but they got
him but I got him mm-hmm
they say you as he was pulling up to his
grandmother's house
authorities were waiting for him damn
he's probably gonna get his girl to make
him something to eat
yeah probably just trying to get a nice
pie or something yeah oh there's a lot
of blood I'm sure you know that's sad
man well I can Nick buzzkill a nice man
it was Louisiana related how about this
man i'ma bail you out here Nick I'm
gonna tell everybody about the ridge
wallet one thing say your country is
under strife and you live in Venezuela
right you're having trouble hiding your
funds because people are coming at night
from the government to get your money
well you know where they're gonna look
they're gonna look in your wallet and
now you don't you can hide your wallet
in the front of your Park in the front
of your pants because that is the ridge
wallet it's that front pocket carry and
it's a beautiful piece and I carry one
and it's in the car right now we can
keep all your credit cards in it and it
just makes it you're not counting on
this big but you know this bucket of
junk on the but a lot of people they get
scoliosis or spina bifida all kind of
things
wasn't there a movie bridge - spina
bifida did you see that Bridge to
Terabithia yeah that's something enough
Bridge to Terabithia but there's all
types of things where you know that for
you you're just carrying your but you're
pocketing your button ear you're
straight up near you be whole is
old-fashioned so get with the times get
that front pocket Kerry Ridge wallet go
to Ridge wallet calm slash Theo and use
code Theo at checkout for 10% off that's
code th EO for 10% off at Ridge wallet
comm and as always if you have thoughts
or suggestions or questions or if you're
struggling with something and you think
that um you need somebody to read you
know - and you need somebody to talk to
or something we don't man the line 24/7
but we do have a voice mail and it's
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero
three and thank you guys so much for
coming out in Dallas we sold out the
shows man is so different man it's so
much I get so stressed getting there we
did the single mom - that looks fun you
got your toes did yeah I got my toes
dead man and it's wild in there have you
ever been to a mom make a pedicure but
this [ __ ] is intense dude I mean they
put you in them they put your walk they
put your feet in the hot water and you
feel like I don't know man you just feel
you feel nice you know you feel special
you feel like you just like the I don't
know it's like somebody really cares
about you if they [ __ ] around with
your feet underwater cuz you wouldn't
even let somebody do that in a pool
imagine you're at the Hampton Inn or
something and they got one of them
heated pools you know over there in
Mishawaka or wherever you're from and
somebody comes you know swimming under
it with a pair of scissors near your
feet dude you're gonna kick that guy in
the [ __ ] face bro it's true but these
people do it right and the single mom
came out yeah uh well you'll learn more
about it we'll put an episode up we're
putting one up tomorrow too aren't we
mm-hmm from the Salt Lake City single
mom yes sir and you can find that on the
either the regular channel or the Theo
von Clips Channel do you ever feel
greedy Nick that you live in America and
like other places struggle yeah I think
about how how lucky I am sometimes when
you yeah you look at any number of
countries and life would be drastically
different yeah do you think it's because
you don't know probably that it's
different in some places like you don't
know I mean you might hear that they
have this and that in America and you
might but if you don't have a tell you
know if it's really rural then you might
not even have a television or anything
it's true you're just getting word of
mouth and it's like then it's just like
how good can somebody describe you know
NFL 2k you know it's kind of gets to
that you know it's like but yeah it's
wild man it's and then also you start to
see the problems if you have a country
that's to comfort
you know Opia you know we get into
things where there's just more addiction
and I wonder I wonder if there's a book
out there that talks about the pitfalls
of a country that gets to count you know
that it just has that's had too much for
too long you know like generation a
generation of comfort I I definitely
have thought that's a lot it seems like
depression and some mental health issues
are so much more prevalent nowadays and
I do think it's because we have so much
less proud problems people just swim in
their feelings yeah and can only they
only have time to think about themselves
whereas before you were worried about
pretty much survival essentially yeah
[ __ ] man you pretty much just some me uh
a lot of us yeah yeah it is it's like
this infection of too much of us and and
even too much of us of just ourselves
you know it's weird because we're build
I think humans are built to be very
interactive creatures and when you're
constantly you know in you know
interacting with others you get a
complete vibe of who you are you know
it's hard to feel like if you start to
feel bad somebody notices immediately
and like what's going on but now in
today's culture in America a lot of
times you just spend a lot of time by
yourself so you first of all you don't
even get a lot of times somebody else
will notice really what's going on
sometimes before you will by just a
little bit of your demeanor change or a
look in your eyes and you don't get that
reflection you don't get people saying
hey what's up you don't even seeing
anyone so then whatever that is inside
of you that someone else would recognize
now it's just sitting and it's faster
and it starts to grow and then by the
time you see somebody do it everybody
you know you're chirp down you know you
you know you cutting your own bangs and
[ __ ] Eaton's olaf's that's how it
happens
I've been happened to me in Charleston I
was gonna say it's something incredibly
specific yeah it sure did you know
petting some ladies cat who's your
ex-girlfriend that you hitchhiked to go
see on her front porch at about sunrise
Taylor's oldest time Jesus and realizing
man this is uh this is how things don't
end well right here this is the
beginning of how things don't end well
and praise God you go back to the place
you're staying in and go to bed on the
couch
but yeah it's you know we're just so you
know someone's almost wish that we
didn't have as much you know because I
wonder if I'd know more about myself as
a person like as my human spirit I think
that's why some like physical activities
like people putting themselves through
struggle like tough mudders and stuff I
think that's why and like the prevalence
of like MMA and stuff it and jiu-jitsu
people pushing themselves putting
yourself through struggle on purpose
because through our daily lives it's so
easy so I think putting yourself through
struggle you can you can learn about
yourself like you were wondering tune
that up huh you can see really start to
tune that I need to do that then I need
to really get in tune with myself man
that's time to do some tuning I think
this year but first I'm gonna [ __ ]
take a nap that's for damn sure where
ain't such an American statement right
there oh I'm gonna [ __ ] tighten up
brother I can taste a nap coming on so
now I taste a month in my mouth oh my
god maybe nap time play that nap
roulette where you go to bed no alarm
set oh wow could wake up half-hour next
day you could miss work yeah yeah yeah I
do that's why that's uh that's
definitely a dark art we had some people
came out somebody brought me some
Pedialyte this week they saw me drinking
on King in the sting and I'm not gonna
drink that anymore maybe I just it's way
too much sugar I didn't know it and did
I drink in four in about an eight-hour
period and I definitely I couldn't keep
my eyes open the afternoon I was sugared
down which is 300 grams of sugar
oh yeah that's like base like putting a
bag of sugar into your ass like one of
those big bags that mom used to have
when you're growing up just right in the
ass bra but yeah dude every you know
things are getting softer dude always
thinking about this so a lot of
c-section babies they should tell you if
somebody's a c-section baby or if they
went through the canal you know if
there's a real Andy Dufresne you feel me
I said I would take a man 600 years to
gather this here prison but Andy
Dufresne did it in less than 9
because do premature babies they get
[ __ ] out the gig they cut out they
get a little you know they get the red
carpet somebody reaches in there and get
you
I had the [ __ ] tighten my head up
into the shape of a vagina and squeezed
myself out into the world and you got
these little pre not premature as man am
i bad um you got these little whatever
they you know c-section bay heaters yeah
basically the New England Patriots of
humans running around and they should
put it right on your neck CS or in be
baby them natural birth is breath that
vag route son you know I'm taking I'm
taking that front door Annie brother
that's what they call me because I'm
coming through the front door ain't
[ __ ] having somebody come in with a
hatchet and take me out of the attic
like a little [ __ ] you know I'm saying
I know my mother I know my mother dude
Jesus Christ sorry getting carried away
let's get carried away with this right
here I'm talking about Skillshare this
past weekend is brought to you by
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators with
more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and career and what's the way
that people could use skills share do
you think Nick there's plenty if you
want to learn social media you've got a
business you want to market social media
is a great way they have plenty of
classes on that you can learn
specialties
I mean think of a skill that you don't
know how to do yeah they're probably
gonna have a class for it and they could
do it within hours you could
armwrestling you know they don't have
that one probably but but they have
everything you can probably think of
except for armwrestling and so it's a
great place to go to you can take
classes yep in social media marketing
mobile photography creative writing or
even illustration what once was
something you had to go to get you you
know you had to get the GED and you had
to get cleared by the courts off the
drugs and piss tests and finally get
over to the Community College just so
you could learn about you know Alfred
Newman or whatever um who did
electricity Benjamin Franklin
benny frank rusty could learn about him
now that's all a wrap dude get on
Skillshare join the millions of students
already learning skill share today with
a special offer just for our listeners
get two months of skill Sheriff for free
that's right skill share is offering
this past weekend listeners two months
of unlimited access to over 25,000
classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm sliced th EO
vo n to start your two months now
Skillshare comm slash co bond let's get
into a couple calls that cool neck yeah
let's do it
yeah I'm sorry guys I'm a little just
tuckered out today but I am uh you know
I am happy to be here with you guys
somebody brought me a nice gift this
weekend it was like a traveling kit I'm
just like taking care of yourself and
that sort of thing just like a little
toothpaste and you know body lotion so
pretty enjoyable let's take a call right
here here we go thank you I just wanted
to respond to the what it means to be a
fan question throughout I feel for you
man
you know I'm a die-hard Bears fan yeah
oh yeah and the last week we talked
about what it was like to be a fan and
what it meant to people because I found
it just so deafening after the silence
by the NFL and the bad call in the
Saints Rams game it made me feel like
even if I'm a fan of my team that's an
that there's a bigger picture going on
that isn't a fair that I'm not even
cheering on something that's in a fair
fight and so that is a and that that
lessens the my I feel like it cheapened
the value of my investment when they
don't have proper officiating and they
can do something better and they choose
not to and the Commissioner chooses not
to even speak on it but yet still to
find the guy they find the guy didn't
they mm-hmm for that helmet Alma they
find the guy
so saying yes this is wrong you need to
pay us button
but not dealing with like the actual
immediate repercussions of it because
everybody else got fine all the fans got
fined I feel like I got fined a billion
dollars in emotions you know and in just
it just it cheapen the value of what I
felt like it meant for me to invest my
my care and heart into the NFL and I
think you did for everybody a little bit
you're like oh is this seat what the
[ __ ] even going on here you know what
do you think Nick
it definitely hit me when you were
talking about how you felt like that
outcome was supposed to be destiny drew
brees Tom Brady I had that same thing in
2003 with my Green Bay Packers hmm that
was the year the game right before
Christmas Brett Favre's dad died and
they played Monday Night Football he had
399 yards four touchdowns
I think bigger from heaven was touching
some of those balls and then the next
week for Christmas I got Packer tickets
to the my first ever Packer game I went
to the season finale they won they beat
the Broncos and the Vikings lost at the
last second to put the Packers in the
playoff Wow and then the next week a
buddy asked me to go to that game and I
got to go to a playoff game so I got to
go to Packer games in a row and that was
the overtime game where it's Matt
Hasselbeck overtime he's like we want
the ball we're gonna score and he threw
a pick six to al Harris he ran the other
way and it just seemed like everything
Brett Favre was supposed to win a Super
Bowl and he's all coming ahead and then
what happened and they lost him fourth
and 26 to the Eagles in just it was four
to 26 they completed a fourth down and
they uh they ended up losing it Brett
Favre was supposed to avenge his
father's death win a Super Bowl and ride
off into the sunset it didn't happen
I've always like had a little less
enthusiasm since that season right but
was there a play by a referee that had
anything to do with it
nick barnett [ __ ] us up but he was it
wasn't a referee it was just like it was
one guy who just like had like a lapse
judgment but it wasn't like there it's
like okay we're having a swim contest in
the water but suddenly there's
water in this area of the pool but
you're still you know it's like it
wasn't like the template of the the the
place like it wasn't like the template
suddenly disappeared you know it wasn't
like you know within a with the official
it just felt like I don't know man it
just felt like why do I care so much if
they don't care about the product that
they're creating mm-hmm it felt like an
on and they're always you know with the
commercials and everything like yeah you
got to support your team you know care
get tickets and now there's a lawsuit I
think filed against um against the NFL
by some season ticket holders who feel
like they've been wronged and I don't
blame them I don't blame them if they
should have a better way to officiate
games and after they find the guy
they're even really admitting to some of
that to some of that uh their inability
I don't even know I'm [ __ ] running
out of words today but anyway did I
interrupt you let's go brother homeward
actually wanted to see the Rams upset
the same but [ __ ] not like that I mean
that that they got a lot yeah I
appreciate you saying that man you know
what's funny is I cheer for this I mean
I love the Saints I cheer for them but I
always cheer fairly I want fair stuff I
don't like it if there's a bad call even
if it goes my team's way that doesn't
that's not right to me that's not fair
because if something isn't fair then
nothing else then it just it's not it's
not right it's not a safe template for
Pete for then the two teams to compete
in that's like putting a field at a
little bit of a slant and then have it
on play soccer on it it's like well yeah
this team's gonna probably win because
the ball is going downhill it just has
to be a fair playing field man I just
think it has to own what you got robbed
and and I like what you said about you
and your friends just not being able to
talk laughter you know kind of just
hanging in with my cousin after seeing
my bears loose you know and then when
the game ended
I did I didn't even know what to text
them you know you just you don't know
what to say but I think being in a fan
is is you know taking the good with the
bad you know I'm a Bears fan and I kind
of inherited it from my my dad is from
Chicago but you know he told me from a
young age you root for your home team
you know you're from Louisiana you don't
you don't root for the Falcons ya know I
mean that's a I mean that's ya you root
for the place you're from and you stick
through them through thin and thick
thick and thin yeah but when the people
servant thick and thin right but when
the people serving the food you know
they ain't giving everybody the same
amount then you know it's just it's hard
you know then everybody doesn't have a
chance to be thick or thin and that's
what kind of what I felt like happened
but yeah man you know it's my second
favorite team is the Bears and I love I
hope true Biscay does well beautiful
eyes on that man you ever seen him in
the helmet I haven't sheared God man I
mean I never really looked at him that
harm but it seemed like he got good eyes
in his head but yeah it's just messed up
man it's messed up that that just the
the lack of accountability by Roger
Goodell menu that [ __ ] Ben Watson called
him out this week you or the leader of
the league you could have you should
have said something you at the very but
silence is just it's obviously you feel
like something's [ __ ] up but they're
still gonna play these other games it
just you know and I wish there were more
home team stuff I wish that States took
players colleges got players just from
their state I wish that that then those
players went on to play for the pro team
I just think would be so much more
exciting or not exciting but it'd be so
much more like a sense of home and a
sense of being and purpose could you
imagine you know if they got a you know
all the players on the team or from your
state or from your town or from your air
you know like you would be everybody be
fired up be so exciting but then I also
think sometimes that state governments
would be better you know I feel like
sometimes when you're trying to mass you
know mass manage
everything at this big level that is
just especially went places are so
different place they're so different
these days in America I think much more
different than they used to be let's go
on to another call man thank you for
calling I think mm-hmm yeah all right
let me hit another one right here and
Nick isn't always in the studio
sometimes he's in sometimes he's not
he's helping me out today because I just
had a long morning I mean literally
within in exactly 48 hours I went to
Dallas
we took the single mom out right when I
got there did the two shows got back to
my hotel went to sleep got up did a yoga
worked out went to the shows we got back
home did a couple hours of sleep got on
the plane came here and took a nap for
one hour I mean that's just life I'm
complaining but it's just like you're
[ __ ] like where's my brain even you
know I feel like it's off the belt the
tollway and uh somewhere out there in
Dallas let's take another call right
here here we go hey wassup vo this is
Josh from Casey man hey Josh from Casey
brother and I wish you had a throat
lozenge right now let's hear more thank
you for calling man come on about super
uh deal but the fan the fan I'm a big
cheese fan actually I lost my boy seoeon
at the stream on Sunday wow he just
really showed me up there Josh um man
and you know what has been fun as I'm
watching the Chiefs man is so exciting
it's like watching the video game but in
human form that no-look pass highlight
yeah Patrick mahomes has is one of the
craziest place I've ever seen in my life
that's a new thing don't even [ __ ]
look well he's so good he really should
just throw it down the field I like it's
almost crazy but I love it I think it
creates it sets the bar higher and it's
nice to see a mix dude doing something
named hour yeah bass power baby it's the
best we can do is why guys is to be
mixed as far as athletics go and uh
so it's good to see him out there let's
hear more onward brother and I'm sorry
for you guys as loss but congratulations
on an amazing and I can't even imagine
more of an exciting team watch all year
than being a Chiefs fan just the
excitement every time they snap the ball
that it's gonna be fun to watch two
seasons ago they didn't have a wide
receivers score a touchdown all season
and now Wow like the most electric
offensive leave things can change fast
dude and that's why you need that bud
elegance you feel me keep your booty
tight and moist
don't go anybody that goes dry paper on
a bee hole bruh it really does sound
old-school I mean it's like what is it
1760 get that B d'Elegance bro onward
raspy but uh I'm not show up in Omaha
I had the Chiefs Jersey on and stuff
well I think I remember this actually
I'm thinking it was a Travis Kelce
Jersey but I could be wrong homeward
well yeah man we lost a heartbreaker as
well end up scoring 24 points in the
fourth quarter we go to overtime didn't
even see the football lost it damn Tom
Brady actually I end up taking my time
pretty shirt out in the driveway poor
Jeff London on fire oh praise God
brother as you should have dude and also
if you find anybody in town named Tom
Brady you should put a couple of [ __ ]
nice in that person homework no lie but
uh I feel your pain man you haven't been
there in 50 years women sue bowling you
guys wanted about 10 years ago so have
some positivity in that so anyway now
I'm a big fan I will see you in KC and I
feel your pain love you man
thanks man that's funny cuz now I feel a
little bit better wonder why I mean I
guess I feel better because I don't
guess he reminded me of of just of just
that they had somebody else who'd had it
worse you know I can't imagine at least
in Louisiana you know don't get that
cold I mean it's probably harder to be
[ __ ] you know your team sucks any
cold
that's crazy imagine us opening the
freezer in your apartment and standing
there for three hours and your team
sucks
that seems really rocky so thank you
Manny you know it does it puts it in
perspective and sometimes I guess that's
what we do for each other is put things
in perspective which is another thing
about like running into people and how
these days will get caught up in our
emotions and our feelings and get
overwhelmed and we just get lonesome and
we get disconnected because when you
running other people it gives you
perspective you know like I like that's
one thing I that made me really struggle
here in LA was I've never ran I never
saw anybody I was always by myself and
so you you see other people but it's not
interactive Ellie's a very it's not a
connected place it's like being at the
airport but outside you know for
everywhere is the airport that's what it
feels like to me and and and you so you
don't get a react you don't get like
people aren't invested they don't care
so you don't see people and they're like
oh what's going on today how are you oh
you look great you look happy like you
don't there's just not that that
reflection of yourself that you get from
seeing other people let's take another
call
how did that sound Nick sounds great
here we go hey this is Blair from
Indianapolis I'm just just calm in
response to the being a fan sports fan
thanks for calling Blair and and I
appreciate you calling and being a
sports fan Indianapolis the Colts at
Andrew luck ran out here we go one thing
I got to say about that is it's man I've
been a fan since I was a little kid I
used to men to be honest with you I used
to cry you know when my team would lose
get real emotion on its training but
here recently I was kind of simmer down
on all that and not really let you know
a team defined exactly how I feel all
the time even though I still love sports
but you know didn't exactly let let that
show exactly my feelings on things so
I'm from
nathless oh my my big thing was the
Pacers and pistons brawl a long time ago
I was about in fourth grade at that time
so I man I couldn't believe it I looked
up from doing homework and they were in
the stands and it was it was pandemonium
so just watching that and then seeing
our season crashed that year when we
could have worn just really there's a
long time ago but really uh crushed
crushed me that year and and ever since
then I don't know if I've ever gotten
back into sports like I used to but
there you go
so if you like getting close can just
like kind of ruin you for getting that
close can kind of ruin you forever mmm
as being a fan loses some of your
enthusiasm yeah it's risky it's risky
and that's why I don't like when it
comes to the officiating which is
something that can be even it can be
that they can't figure it out I mean it
just put a damn sensor in the ball and
on the players I mean I know it takes
out the but then maybe it takes out all
the joy I don't know but then I can't
even imagine before they didn't replay
if you were just guess and what the [ __ ]
was going on so I can't imagine some of
the robbery that's occurred over the
years it'd be interesting to go back and
see some of those like how did that
knock like today he would have been
furious and also that's another thing in
America we expect everything to be kind
of perfect we expect things to be
even-keeled
you know we expect it to be a fair fight
everywhere which is a good thing and a
bad thing I think but man you'd think
the NFL could get it tightened up thank
you for calling man the Pacers fan you
gave up when they fall it yeah something
can take you out and I think that's part
of it too part of me I'm worried about
how am I gonna feel next season
am I gonna care as much because you
don't watch a lot of games this year I
would I bought the NFL Sunday Ticket
like I did things I hadn't done gave up
my money of my time you know I had a
bunch of conversations with friends
you know it's a lot of us your time you
know I looked for a lot of joy in
watching the Saints and cheering them on
and and when they're playing in a place
that's not a fair place to play I'm like
well [ __ ] what do I care it's not
fair it's not a good investment of my
time so let's hear more I feel like
we've talked about this a lot already
homeward
what's up Pio it's Alex Cole again from
LA Alex coming from LA homeward I just
thought you know about this past weekend
and did he call before noon he said
again I think we haven't used his
voicemail okay first time okay let's
hear more um it started off just me
going to work and getting a weird
feeling with her boss and she calls me
outside and she fired me so I got fired
for my job
and on my way damn she sounds kind of
sexy more way at home and getting fired
I was hit by two cars in a threesome
automobile accident I messed up my wrist
kind of bad so my car got totaled and
during the accident my phone hit the
windshield from my passenger seat and
broke into a million pieces it didn't
break into a million pieces dude I mean
I could see it breaking but it
definitely didn't that's am i calling
you out bro but that's from wild cliche
to use in that moment careful with the
hyperbole yeah dude it broke maybe it
shattered and kind of broke some but
anyway you could just set my anyway what
the [ __ ] am I talking about
now how many cars actually hit him you
know yeah that's true yeah you hurt your
wrist bro first of all who even has a
wrist dude most people just don't even
[ __ ] think about the wrist did your
wrist your hand will be fine bro their
skin connecting it
you got a dude you got a tough toughen
up you're working for a lady first of
all that's awesome man good for you
times are different and it's okay and
I've worked for many women over the
years and I know a lot of them
there are married or as they like to
call it working for a woman so I we can
all relate to that but dude didn't you
get into a three-car collision and all
that happened she's you're at your
[ __ ] wrist bruh man up dude [ __ ]
die or don't get hurt at all
none of this middle ground do you it's a
[ __ ] kids are getting soft man that's
America you don't some opioids dude
won't you do that he had some here's one
more thing happened to him though and I
lost my job my car or my phone in like
an hour and that so you know I didn't
let it get me down but kind of sucked a
little bit so the next morning I have to
walk a couple miles to school the school
what's going on here
I would help well how old are you every
age let's hear more well I get stuff
figured out and I go to Citrus College
in the zuzo and there was a school
scream scare so we got a lockdown for 10
hours and that was my past weekend
I've had I've had better with gents for
sure but I'm not gonna let it get me
down you know damn bra do we listen more
Nicki thing no he's not gonna let him
get it down wow dude
I think you might want to go to church
or something dude or wrap yourself in
bubble wrap Dawg this might be your time
and you're out there cheating death so I
don't know how you handle that you know
do you can't be cheating death brother
you got to tighten up so I don't know
what to do I would give it the church or
get with you you know some Latinos that
are older you know from some of the old
city and see if they could do some [ __ ]
put some hex on you or something you
know I'm saying do that voodoo baby you
know put a couple of your feet I think
if you pull a couple of your sisters
chin hairs out and put them in your
buttocks or whatever they got that old
voodoo make you stay safe but beat do be
well man it might be in my last name
time we ever hear from that guy so be
well Steve is that his name Alex yep
see he's even change his name who
[ __ ] knows bruh
even nose man but be safe Alex and good
luck out there at least you're walking
to school and getting it done you know
at least you're getting it done and I'm
moving onward let's take another call
here what's up there Jamie from Perth
Australia gang gang brother how's it
thank you for calling we don't get a lot
of Australian callers you know I get a
lot of messages on Instagram that they
can't call here for something so I think
are they only get one call a day aren't
the only in jail or something is it yeah
that's what they're all in the history
book I said they sent them all over
there because they did some yeah they're
all convicts unbelievable man but you
guys are welcome here brother
we're all guilty of something here
brother and I'm coming over there
tickets are gonna sail February 11th and
um and I'm coming over there soon and
I'm also gonna be in Columbus Ohio next
weekend but let's hear more I just
wanted to say towards the end of last
year I started no I decided to make a
change
I was thinking being such a fat [ __ ] I
was weighing in it like 120 kilos I'm
ready like five foot seven like I was a
unit do Donna Hartman's Hartman's when
he kilos is a huge 265 pounds at five
seven oh my gosh bro you're like a
loveseat change my diet since October
I've dropped 20 kilos down to 100 on the
dot just started going to the gym man I
just want to say you know listening to
your podcast and the struggles that your
listeners and yourself go through helped
me really keep my head down and and get
through via the drastic change and not
even like such a [ __ ] pig so thanks
man
can't wait for you to come out to
Australia I know you said tickets on
sale early said hopefully you come in a
purse we do miss out on a few shows from
music and comedians and older speakers
on the other side of the country but you
know man it's a good city if you come
down I'll show you around there's this
little wildlife park you can hold a
wombat he status [ __ ] this little wall
madam an infusion when that when they
get you to hold him he's uh he's not to
just straight at the camera he's balls
just hanging out damn dude
reminds me my stepdad while mom first
met him
that's pretty funny but anyway bro you
take care man keep doing what you're
doing
Gang Gang baby gang gang mate thank you
for calling brother yeah and I will be
coming to Perth when I'm there so you
know hold a wombat dude I'll go hold a
wombat I don't know if I hope that's not
like a code for something you know
because I'm not trying to get it you
know I mean but ya know I'm very excited
man I'm very excited been a lot of
support from the podcast and just for
you know the comedians that I run with
and my own comedy from Australia and I
and I'm really really excited I'm
extremely excited to be coming down
there yeah it's almost you know uh and I
can't believe that that change you must
feel you must feel like you escaped a
prison can't imagine what it's like to
be in that much weight you know to be in
there and feel like you're like somebody
who's just like trapped somewhere like
you're just wearing two sleeping bags or
something so I commend you man I commend
you for what finding whatever that
strength and that spark a lot of times
it's a spark you need that spark to get
you started that's why a lot of times
people don't change their life until
they hit like rock bottom you know they
need a spark they need something you
know people don't stop smoking til they
get cancer people don't stop [ __ ]
till they get kids you know people don't
you know stop you know doing magic until
somebody beats the [ __ ] out of them for
doing magic so it's like sometimes you
gotta have you know something really
come along and adjust you and I'd be
curious to know what that spark was that
really got you motivated because that's
a big change you know when I struggle
with small things just like you know
like you know I smoke a cigarette at
night and I've been doing good but uh I
just haven't been able to just beat it
you know get five days here three days
there but the masterbation have been
able to I think I'm like fifty days now
oh no I jerked off on Friday night sorry
but I'm talking about pornography
and I've been off that for a while I
think almost 50 days and man it is kind
of nice because
slowly all the stuff that the junk in
your head starts to go away and I'm able
to think a little bit differently I feel
like I hope anyway I hope I have a new
experience with that because I'm tired
of I'm tired of just seeing all of that
over the years I don't need it we don't
need it but thank you for your call man
and I'll be down there soon let's take
let's read another ad huh how about that
I'm gonna tell you if you're not gonna
go down under but if you just want to
bone out and if you like sex you're
gonna love blue chew calm blue chew it's
a performance enhancement for the
bedroom you wouldn't you like to last
longer and go extra rounds I personally
would not I like to go one round and
last just a medium amount of time but
blue Chu makes the first chewable with
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis at a lower price than those other
two tired of your kid running around the
house [ __ ] slip him on blue chew his
whole body will lock up and he won't be
able to move at all
damn look at that little bone or in a
diaper he won't be running anywhere I'm
just joking but chewables work faster
than pills up to twice as fast and blue
choom makes that first chewable it only
takes a few minutes to fill out the form
online
there's no doctor visit no awkward
conversation no waiting in line at a
pharmacy ships directly to your door in
discreet packaging blue chewables are
prescribed online by a doctor and made
in the USA amen blue chill gives you
confidence in bed every time you and
your partner will love it here's a great
deal for our listeners visit blue to
calm and get your first order free when
you use promo code th EO just pay five
dollars shipping that's B lu e CH e w
comm and promo code th e o go get your
dick right go get that blue qu o let's
get into another call here Nick I'm
tired man I'm sorry man
here we go what's going on Co is J from
Boston what's up J from Boston which I
feel like everybody's naming ball
but that's okay man I'm happy to hear
from you today and I'm so excited we
just added in another show at the Wilbur
and man it's kind of weird I've been
thinking about it it's like I can't
imagine like going out and being like in
a theatre you know that's just gonna be
so crazy like I've done it once or twice
but like to go and do a night where
there's two shows at a theater and
there's all those people there man I
can't even believe it it makes me feel
like I don't know I just feel so excited
so that's really really keeping me
pretty uplifted coming up and all of it
has man all of it has so you know this
weekend my man one of my agents I talked
to him and you know I got into the club
Friday night and I was a rat I was just
like just stressed to the gills and just
overwhelmed and and he said he got a
call from one of the managers at the
club and said that I hadn't been really
super nice you know and so it really was
like a moment where I was like [ __ ] man
I gotta check myself you know I gotta
just like my own stress I'm not even
seeing what's going on outside of me you
know so that was like a moment that it
was like most people would might be
pissed if somebody said hey man you you
know we got a call from the comedy club
and they said that you know and no [ __ ]
no no shame at the club they weren't
angry they were just like you know they
didn't think some of my behavior was
good you know and it's kind of
embarrassing to admit that but but I was
just so grateful man because I need it
cuz suddenly I just felt like a little
bit just like I guess humility or I
don't know what it was I just felt I
knew I was looking for something just to
shut not just to change my straw like I
just been just so erratic and I needed
somebody just to kind of put me in my
place but just tell me hey shits
you're not running at the frequency you
want to be at and may and so I felt bad
about myself for a couple minutes and
then
I just started just I just was just
grateful because I know that if I can
find things you know that just remind me
to keep my act right then uh then I'll
be fine
and the rest of the weekend was great
did you talk to the club at all oh yeah
yeah I went person to person and just
apologize for hey you know sorry if I
was you know stressed out last night if
I was rude to you
you know I told him unto said I've just
been under a lot of stress and you know
sometimes I just feel like uh like I
don't know what's going on but I'm
moving fast at the same time and it's
kind of a scary feeling you know now
that Club though I'm sure the shows went
great you seem they always do but they
probably like like you even more after
having that interaction where you're
like no I was not acting right I'm sorry
that's not like that's not that's not a
good representation of me yeah he you
put a better foot forward and now they
probably really fond of you I would
imagine it takes a lot to apologize to
people well that's nice you to say man
yeah no I'm glad it happened you know I
needed I just needed because I wasn't
feeling just in the sink you know I get
I just wasn't feeling like myself I was
feeling edgy and I'm feeling angry you
know and that sometimes I don't even
know why I think someone was just like
just oh there's just not a lot of
downtime you know it's like we're doing
a lot here we got King in the sting and
it's all good stuff it's weird it's like
it's all fun stuff we get the pot TV
pilots starting tomorrow and then the
shows on them it's all good I think some
of it's just some adjustment but yeah at
first I was sad and just kind of
disappointed in myself but then I was
just so happy that something finally it
just made me feel like hey man you know
get real bruh you know look what you
know recognize what's going on and it
was good I needed it man yeah and after
that it was good man tipped everybody on
the staff and everybody that cooks
everybody and you know it was just and
then it was so much more of a pleasant
experience because I thought that they
were
now I remember I thought that they were
not kind of doing their jobs but the
truth was they really were and they were
excited for me to be there I couldn't
even see any of that because I'd come in
with this own perspective of mind that I
was just flustered so suddenly nothing
was right that's what it was nothing was
right and the truth was that they were
it kind of eliminated the opportunity
for some of the workers there who were
fans who were listeners to the play and
it eliminated the opportunity for them
to have a moment with me you know and to
be able to say like hey hello cuz you
know I'm just erratic in it so I feel
bad that I you know that I cost me you
know me and them some of those good
opportunities because those the
opportunities really that make me have
the joy in the going to do the shows the
most in the first place is just
interacting with people and see how
excited they are about the material and
me getting to you know do the jokes for
them so I'm just grateful I'm just
grateful that's something that I had a
moment this shook me a little bit and
then one of my agents was honest enough
with me about it
and he said yeah it wasn't nothing
overwhelming you know and everybody was
there was cool but then it by the end it
was really great so but [ __ ] did I
interrupt this guy again - hey I'm here
buddy cap sorry I'm so sorry man oh
we're I just wanted to say thank you
because I'm 60 days clean from
pornography and jerking off in your
podcast you've been a big help
dang boy you sound wet baby you sound
like you got a little bit of gargling
your throat right like you're running on
some [ __ ] intercede baby Oh word I
found out about you last year and you've
got me through some hard times man but
nothin but podcast is what made me fully
commit to staying off that spanking
train and I appreciate that all abort
get off that spanking train this is the
last stop that spanking train gotta
think about it some of you [ __ ] wild
cats how many times if you beat off your
animal how many times until it's enough
how much is enough you greedy bastard
how much see you're gonna spill out of
your body the salt of the earth of thing
that gives you manatee life and you're
dumping it around like [ __ ] Johnny
Apple spank get your life right I love
you brother home where J let's hear more
I'm gonna be seeing you live in March
it's a Wilbur theater with my older
brother and we're gonna eat a little bit
of that funky fungus and get trippy if
you know what I'm saying so keep
fighting the dark arts brother we love
you we love seeing you do well you the
man just just kill it you keep doing you
right Bo gang brother yellow mushroom
just to come backstage man every
hilarious brother see you guys dude
that's so cool you get to do mushrooms
with your brother man that's cool you
know stuff like that I miss out on you
know but I love that dude and thank you
I'm so happy man you sound boisterous
bro
you sound boisterous man you full of
that [ __ ] spunk brah dude you could
probably cry a little bit of semen right
now if you tried real hard and that's
beautiful man and that's what our higher
power once they want us to be full of
seed so we can interact with the world
instead of walking around like a [ __ ]
leaky tank all the time that's me that's
the old me brother but now I'm keying up
and I'm keeping my bag
[ __ ] full ba ba ba beat spank have
you any wool
oh no let me try it again Bob beat spank
have you any seed yes sir yes sir
two bags bowl pretty bad all right let's
take one more call here as always the
numbers ninety five six six four nine
five zero three hey Theo this is Jay I
wanted to talk about the dark side of
eating I'm listening to your podcast
right now with Kevin thank you for
calling in Jay and that's our second Jay
today and good luck to the other JT New
England Patriots man oh and you know
when I was in Marine Corps boot camp we
always ate together and we didn't have
stall doors on the bathroom so we had
the number two we would always be
looking right at each other and talk
and you know just chit-chatting about
everything but I mean that's uh that's
the dark side of evening that was
honestly that's probably some of the
best conversations I've ever had in my
life was and that negative aspect of
eating food coming out the rear in it
yeah man I think that's a damn Dutch
bakery dude I've heard of a Dutch oven
and that's when you you know do body gas
and hide under the and just get it all
to yourself under the sheet but a Dutch
bakery I think is when you sit not I you
know I've called shotgun I've never
called [ __ ] gun brother you feel me when
you guys are sitting looking at each
other from one toilet to another Wow
that's [ __ ] beautiful bro that should
be the state bird man this should be the
that should be the American bird I don't
know what our bird is I think it's a
bald eagle but they're endangered why
not two dudes looking at each other on
[ __ ] bro that's the most American
thing I've ever heard man let's hear
more brother and thank you for your
service dude and for you you know
looking at another man in the eyes while
they [ __ ] good god you should get a
diploma for that I think anyways I'm
going to see a show this weekend and
Irvine can't wait to do that and we'll
see you guys Gang Gang brother yeah that
was two weeks ago in Irvine and that was
a fun show
damn you ever done that Nick I haven't
but I I see the logic in it's like you
got nothing to hide at that point so you
can just be fully honest when you're
talking to someone
yes watching a [ __ ] you're very
vulnerable yeah yeah I got to think
about I gotta talk to my brother what
did we call it could we used to do
sometimes we'd get on the [ __ ] and
you sit back to back when we're real
small and one of us would sit holding
that tank and do duty and the other one
would sit the irregular way and you can
both [ __ ] at the same time interesting
yeah and it was awesome man I mean it
was pretty fun probably one of the only
things we really did together as kids a
lot but um yeah man I'll never forget
that and I didn't like the tank if
you're facing that tank you gotta really
I didn't like that I like the normal way
you know but I always had to ride in the
backseat you know because I'd always
kind of hold that tank because I was a
younger one by Daniel Tosh has a bit ho
he would sit on the toilet and Faye
the tank in the morning because then you
can use that little edge eat your cereal
on the top of the man that's beautiful
that's the dark arts what else did we
get through everything I think we did I
think we did um producer Nick thanks for
being in here with us today no problem
it's my pleasure thanks for holding down
up you have fun with your family in town
yeah we bailed on the Comedy Store last
night so we might try to get him to go
tonight
a membra this has been a very bow sewed
hasn't it somehow it did turn into that
I think he's part of it is because when
you get to like you know where I am
today you're so tired you get down to
just the gray this though down in the
dumps yeah down in the dumps man dirty
you get down in the dumps
all right I'll I'll see you guys uh I'll
talk to you guys on Thursday thank you
guys you guys uh on the the music on the
way in was my boy Stevie starlight and
it's never too late to come over and
we'll do that again and and if you have
a thought do you know uh you know keep
me in your thoughts as week as we tape
this up this pilot for Comedy Central
you know a lot of it's out of my control
but a lot of the opportunity to have fun
this week and is show up to my job is
going to be in my control and so I want
to show up with a good attitude and and
just a grateful attitude you know and
just man pretty fortunate to be able to
be living out some of my dreams and and
um and it's just weird that part of me
inside of me wants to [ __ ] mess it up
somehow you know it's like there's these
it's the dark hearts brother I might
need that bad elegance for my soul man
I might need really I might need that
that soul posit ory you guys be good to
yourselves man I know you deserve it
okay
enjoy your destination